the 11th of august the u.s said that the
taliban were likely to seize the whole
country it was just a question of how
long it was going to take
were you already on holiday
so by the way the the
that is part of the central assessment
that i described
that we thought that they would cease uh
or i mean there are basically a variety
of scenarios between taliban takeover
and civil war but the most likely the
central assessment was that it would be
a taliban consolidation of power
but that it would take
place in the months following the
evacuation and that
that kabul would not fall before the end
of the year
you didn't ask answer my the second
online question were you already on
holiday
uh
a full statement on my holiday i've said
that i wouldn't have gone uh um
away with the benefit of hindsight which
is
the luxury of
did you go and i'm not going to start
chris adding to frankly the the
fishing expedition uh beyond the fact
that i've articulated in a fulsome
statement and having answered questions
uh continuously about that i would just
make the broader point
i'm sorry mr rabb
the problem here is that
of course it's perfectly legitimate for
ministers to go on holiday everybody has
that right and i would argue it's an
important part of people being fresh
enough to be able to do their job
properly the difficulty for us is
that the prime minister was on holiday
and the deputy prime minister yourself
was on holiday and as i understand it
the permanent undersecretary was on hold
all three at the same time
when
british nationals were at risk
many people thousands of people by our
own estimation who stood by us in a
difficult time in afghanistan were in
peril of their lives
and there was still not a proper um
crisis center up in place do you not see
that it's important for british people
to understand why you thought it was
right to go on holiday no sorry i'm
afraid i don't agree with that analysis
of course i've been clear with the
benefit of hindsight i wouldn't have
gone away at all and
the
the charge in relation to officials i
think is particularly unwarranted
because we always make sure that we have
the right cover in place the permanent
secretary did an excellent job uh and
quite right given
all of the ir the sr the merger that he
should
take some leave
in terms of um
my own situation i just say this i'm
traveling today
a modern foreign secretary has to have
the ability given those wide range of
issues that will constantly bubble up
possibly to crisis point to be able to
deal act work
from
abroad i engaged in all of the cobra
meetings
i engaged and directed the emergency
response team
directly uh and
uh i was engaged with international
partners so the uh
the the and the truth is chris judge us
by the results because between the what
the
15th of august and the end of august we
delivered over 15 000 people out of the
country which i think is the uh
certainly the most challenging uh
evacuation of its kind in living memory
and much like mr bryant i think it's
important that people do take holidays
but it's also important to know when to
cut them short
again for the sake of transparency of
your own actions when did you go on
holiday what dates did you go on holiday
not interested in what you did there
what date did you go look i i made it
what did you go on holiday
foreign i think your own personal
transparency is important what date did
you go on holiday i made a full
statement on it uh i will say it was
clear i should have did the statement
include the date that you left at
why can't you just answer this question
this is absolutely because look to be
honest with you i think it's a pretty
partisan political i just want to know
when you guys are being clear
because i think it's important we can
map out you know as mr brian correctly
said earlier we have uk personnel uk
civilians in harm's way
and i think it's important for us to
know what you were doing and where you
were doing it from when did you go on
holiday
i'm not looking to beat you over this i
just want to know when you went